So as always, we're going to start to
simplify this term by identifying the
constant factors in it. So for those, we
have 4 and -3. And remember, we want to
move those to the front of the term, so
that they are the first two factors that
we have written. So this term is equal to
4 times -3 times the variable factors that we
have left over, x, y and x. So right off
the bat we know how to deal with two of the
factors here. We know that 4 times -3 is just
equal to -12. So we can replace 4 times -3
with -12 and then write the 3 remaining
factors. There's something interesting
here though. We have two variables that are
the same. We have x and x. I'm going to
rewrite this one more time with the order
of the variables switched so that the x's
are next to each other. That's just
generally a good rule of thumb in algebra
is to write things that you think are
related to one another next to each other.
This x times x is interesting. This is the
first chance that we're going to get to
use exponents. We've seen them already a
few times in this course, but we haven't
gotten to write our own factors with
exponents in them. So, this may seem like
new material or it may be review for you,
but x times x can also be written with an
exponent as x^2.
In the same way, x * x * x = x^3, and so
on, and so forth. Remember that in all of
these equations right here, I didn't need
to write any of these multiplication
signs. If we had just written the x's
directly next to one another, without any
symbol in between, multiplication would
still have been implied. So instead we
could just have xx equals x^2.
I just wrote this out to be abundantly
clear. The exponents show how many of the
same factor are multiplied together.
Incidentally if 2 x's mulitiplied together
is equal to X^2 then when we have just 1x
is equal to x^1.
This seems a little bit silly to write
though, writing X to the 1 is more
complicated than writing just x so, we
usually don't move from having x to
writing x to the first instead. So using
this information about exponents, we can
replace this x times x with an x^2.
And with that information we can rewrite
this term as -12x^2y.
We're obeying all the conventions we know
about how to write terms because we have
the constant factor at the front, and then
we have our variables in ascending
alphabetical order. We have the x^2 before
the y. That was awesome, I know that this
was a pretty complicated thing that
involved a ton of different concepts, some
of which we haven't focused on a lot yet.
But don't worry if exponents still don't
feel totally comfortable, we're going to
keep working with them a ton more.